las consecuencias de otro ataque ruso un
edificio residencial con las ventanas
destrozadas paredes y suelos
bombardeados y un cuerpo muerto bajo los
escombros el de la periodista de radio
liberty mira escrich para el alcalde de
la capital el bombardeo fue una clara
provocación destinada a captar la
atención de un visitante de alto nivel
esto es un saludo antonio guterres el
señor putin le mostró el dedo disparando
y destruyendo nuestras casas ilusionarse
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
felinski añadió que los ataques del
jueves son una muestra del
comportamiento de moscú esto dice mucho
sobre la verdadera actitud de rusia
hacia las instituciones mundiales sobre
los esfuerzos de los dirigentes rusos
por humillar a la onu y todo lo que la
organización representa una lluvia de
misiles cayó sobre kiev al día de la
reunión del secretario general de la onu
con el líder ucraniano guterres se
encontraba en el país para visitar las
ciudades en las que se habrían cometido
crímenes de guerra por parte de los
rusos horas antes de los atentados había
pedido al kremlin que cooperará con la
corte penal internacional mientras tanto
el ministerio de defensa de rusia no
hizo referencia sobre las viviendas de
los residentes pero dijo que sus fuerzas
destruyeron una planta de cohetes con
ataques de precisión